[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance we all know why Donald Trump
is doing this he has an ego that would
make Napoleon blanch and a power lust it
makes Stalin back off his pimp bladder
Mir Putin has something on him he's
crazy he sees stuff or best-case
scenario he just exploits everyone and
everything he is the parent to whom the
kid shouts out in the middle of the
night crying there are monsters under my
bed and he says you are correct there
are monsters and only I can save you
from the monsters but first turn over
your allowance and sign this
non-disclosure agreement and don't ever
think or say or tell anybody that in
fact I am the monster Trump by now we
get Trump but why are the banana
Republicans who as recently as two
months ago had showed brief ever fading
signs of standing up to Trump why are
they doing this why are they becoming
the vichy government which sold out
France during the Nazi occupation why
are they lining up to become quislings
collaborating with the Germans and
helping kill their fellow Norwegians why
are they applauding a Russian attack on
America well clearly they were only
standing up to Trump because they were
afraid afraid he would lose once Trump
won they saw power and as Eric Blair
once wrote we are interested solely in
power pure power
no one ever seizes power with the
intention of relinquishing it power is
not a means it is an end the object of
power is power mr. Blair published of
course under the name George Orwell so
it's not just about abstract power for
the banana Republicans for the mercenary
monsters like Paul Ryan there is a
specific reason they are backing Trump
for now until he shows signs of losing
again at which point they will kill him
and eat him for Republicans who think
they are using Trump Trump is perpetual
chaff I've mentioned chaff before chaff
is metal debris used by bombers and
missile crews and pilots to confuse
radar and Trump spews chaff every day
every hour every minute and as hard as
we try you and I cannot avoid all of it
and so while he's enraging people by
appointing of a Secretary of Labor who
hates labor and a Secretary of Housing
who hates housing
Secretary of Energy who once couldn't
remember that he wanted to dismantle the
Department of Energy while he's doing
all these other Eric Blair --is-- chat
things and while we're raging about
ambassadorships reportedly being offered
his quid pro quos to get bigger axe to
play at the inaugural or how the self
dealer elect is going to stay on as
executive producer one of the worst
shows ever on television and while we
pull out our hair because the self
dealer elects last campaign manager says
he will do that in his spare time while
all that chaff is flying the banana
Republicans are going on a stealth
offensive they have to reveal themselves
sooner or later if only to signal the
corporation's who own them that yes the
fix is in and ownership will be getting
what they prostituted the government for
for Paul Ryan sooner or later turned out
to be sooner two Thursday's ago a man
named Steven Seagal wrote a letter to
another man named Sam Johnson and in so
doing the cat jumped out of the banana
Republicans bag mr. Goss is chief
actuary of the Social Security
Administration the man who has to assess
the impact of the economy and the
legislation and basically everything in
the world on the future not only of
Social Security but also of those who
receive Social Security and the man he
wrote to mr. Johnson is the Republican
congressman from the third District of
Texas whose chairman of the Ways and
Means committees Subcommittee on Social
Security and on the 8th of this month
mr. Johnson introduced bill HR six four
eight nine the Social Security reform
Act of 2016
mr. Gauss's letter is sixteen pages long
plus fourteen more pages of tables and
graphs and the kind of calculations that
nearly caused me to flunk out of senior
math in high school and but for the
generosity of my math teacher Jerry
Murphy I'd be in my forty second
consecutive year trying to graduate from
high school but it's mr. Johnson's bill
that matters here it explains why the
Republicans are abetting the idiot elect
mr. Gauss's letter explains how deeply
Johnson and Paul Ryan and all the other
corporate [ __ ] intend to plunge the
knife into the back of Social Security
and especially those hard-working fools
of middle america who actually believed
the net impact of a donald trump
presidency would be more
money for them and not you know poverty
in their old age the gist is they're
screwed Social Security not just
Medicaid or Medicare on which it's
always open season in Republican Land
Social Security would be gutted not only
no more money going into Social Security
but actually less money going in and
massive cuts to money going out in
Social Security checks some cuts
starting as soon as December 2018 if
you're making around fifty thousand
dollars your Social Security check would
be cut between 11 percent and 35 percent
this bill or some lesser new version of
it that the banana Republicans would
introduce next year in which instead of
being stabbed to death you just die more
slowly by bleeding to death that's why
Paul Ryan and the Republicans are
supporting Trump ordinary Americans
particularly those Trump voters who will
have taken this Social Security cut
knife and managed to stab themselves in
their own back with it they will be
watching whatever Trump is doing at the
moment
at some point likely to be his version
of Daffy Duck drinking gallon gasoline
bottle of nitroglycerine pile of
gunpowder and a glass of uranium-238 men
lighting a match and in the background
the Republican House and Republican
Senate now full of subsidiaries of the
corporations who are able to buy this
country after citizens united they will
destroy Social Security so the rich can
get even richer by stealing a billion
dollars one dollar at a time and our
part-time president will take a quick
look away from his Twitter feed to sign
exactly where they tell him to sign
close your eyes for a second imagine
you're on a ship that has just sunk and
sunk quickly you have popped up to the
surface next to a large empty lifeboat
it is stocked with provisions to ORS and
room for several dozen people what you
do next defines to me mankind there are
generally two responses in the first you
get in the lifeboat you assess exactly
how many other people can safely fit in
how long you can all last and you begin
to pull in other survivors still in the
water trying to bring in women and
children first and injured but also
people to help you help them and to row
this big boat in the second response you
get in the lifeboat you assess exactly
how long you could
asked if you ate all the food by
yourself and then you pick up one of the
oars and you start swinging it at the
other survivors still in the water
killing them if possible to make sure
you are the only one in the boat
the first response makes you a liberal
also known as a human being the second
response makes you a conservative open
your eyes now
surprisingly as seen in the banana
Republicans Social Security play it now
turns out there's actually a third
response to this in this one you
actually help a couple of other
survivors into that lifeboat and then as
they are leaning over the side trying to
help pull up others you kill them with
the oar and then you steal their wallets
off their dead bodies so you can make a
profit off of them that third response
that makes you Donald Trump resist peace